المسار الذي
يحلق شمالاً لساعات إلى
أقصى شمال روسيا للمنشآت العسكرية
منحتنا موسكو زيارة نادرة
لقاعدتها في فرنسا ،
أرض يوسف ، أرخبيل قاحل في المحيط المتجمد الشمالي ،
لكن روسيا تعتقد أنه المفتاح
للسيطرة على القطب الشمالي ، هذه
القاعدة الجوية بأكملها مغطاة
بالجليد  ومع ذلك ، تمكن الروس من
تمديد المدرج إلى درجة
تمكنهم من الهبوط حتى أثقل
طائراتهم هنا بما في ذلك
القاذفات الإستراتيجية القادرة على حمل
أسلحة نووية ، والجهود التي تبذلها موسكو لتحديث
قواعدها في القطب
الشمالي ضخمة داخل المجمع السكني الحديث
المسمى
الشجرة  احباط القائد الجوي يؤكد
لي أنه حتى قاذفات القنابل الاستراتيجية الروسية من طراز توبوليف 95 الخطيرة ،
يمكن لطائرة مماثلة في الحجم لطائرة
بي 52 الأمريكية
أن تعمل خارج المطار
هنا بالطبع يمكنهم أن يقولوا ألقوا نظرة على
أنه يمكننا الهبوط بجميع أنواع  الطائرات في
هذه القاعدة
هي احتمال تقشعر له الأبدان بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها بالنظر إلى أن أرض فرنسا تقع على
بعد حوالي 160 ميلاً فقط شرق إقليم الناتو.
هذا في نطاق هذه
الصواريخ الدفاعية الساحلية القوية ،
أظهر لنا الروس أيضًا
أنهم قادرون على ضرب السفن على بعد أكثر
من 200 ميل من الساحل ،
وهو تهديد يقلقنا لدينا
مخاوف بشأن بعض الأنشطة العسكرية المتزايدة
في القطب الشمالي أه  مما يزيد من
مخاطر أو احتمالات وقوع الحوادث
حسابات خاطئة
، السبب الرئيسي وراء اشتداد حدة المواجهة
بين الولايات المتحدة وروسيا في
القطب الشمالي
هو تغير المناخ حيث يذوب الجليد القطبي ،
أصبح الوصول إلى المنطقة أكثر سهولة
وتتحرك روسيا بسرعة للمخاطرة
بمطالباتها  يقود هذا الجهد من هنا
مقر الأسطول الشمالي
في بلدة عسكرية مغلقة من مدني
مورس والتي حصلنا عليها أيضًا على
روسيا وقد قامت بترقية أسطولها
هنا منذ سنوات ،
وكان رائدها هو بيتر
طراد المعركة النووية العظيم
المجهز بمجموعة  من الأسلحة
لضرب أهداف في البحر
والأرض ومحاربة الطائرات والغواصات
لدى روسيا استراتيجية واضحة هنا في
القطب الشمالي  د
يدور أساسًا حول ثلاثة أشياء مختلفة
من ناحية ، جيش قوي جدًا
ثم
يسيطر على الطريق البحري الشمالي
وأيضًا استغلال
الموارد الطبيعية وروسيا تحذرنا
وحلفائها من العبث بهذا الكوكب
، لقد كان واضحًا تمامًا
للجميع  لفترة طويلة أن هذه
أرضنا ،
هذه أرضنا ونحن مسؤولون
عن ساحل القطب الشمالي لدينا ليكون آمنًا ،
كل ما يفعله بلدنا ،
هناك خطاب شرعي تمامًا
يجعل الولايات
المتحدة وروسيا على نحو متزايد في مسار تصادم في
أقصى الشمال
مع  موسكو حتى الآن في موقف أقوى
فريد بلاتكين سي إن سيفر ندم روسيا
عليك